hey what's happening it's kevin gates
make sure you check me out on the
bootleg care podcast
bootleg calf show special guests in here
the legendary kevin gates
wow i got a question yeah thank you for
having me of course
could i pray first let's go man we do
this of course let's do it
bismillah
heavens and earth thank you for all the
wonderful blessings in which you
bestowed upon us in this life and in
heaven as the jew forgive us for all our
sins we forget those who sin against us
even the sins we may have committed
knowing and unknown
each and every brother and sister in all
living species those laws find
incarcerated those free
let anything that i say that's uplifting
to people
come from you and you alone
that anything that i say that's not
uplifting the people
come from the shaytan and me i'll be
here responsible
i mean
there it is
you know it's uh the last time i
interviewed you you prayed before the
interview too that was uh
dude with dj head the don't touch me
interview but it wasn't like i think
that that was misinterpreted no i you
know what i tell you yeah you go ahead
go ahead like i understand what you're
saying but please don't touch me again
yeah
i just
it just was different and i'm not trying
to have picks and choosers but some
people
the energy's in alignment other people
the energy is not an alignment and
there's nothing against him he's a great
guy great guy great guy you know what
i'm saying it's just i believe that
maybe my energy was off that day you
know what's interesting about that about
that day was
we did the interview
and after the interview i don't know if
you remember we talked for like an hour
and you played us the album
and you were like man i wish we would
have started the interview now because
now i know y'all and now
you know you step into an unfamiliar
situation
and
it just was it was tense
being that i had just came home i was
yeah you were fresh out i was on
supervised release mm-hmm so i was still
in a different type of mode i was there
can we get the mic in front of you if
you don't mind just yeah
i was still in a transitioning period
from being
in the box to
being back in a society
so you know it was still a little
different for me yeah that was that was
um i always cause people always ask me
about that one moment and i'm always
like you know what i tell them i'm like
you know what's crazy is after the
interview ended we hung out and the
energy was amazing amazing yeah and like
you played us the whole album front to
back and we had good talks like it was
it was it was a that was still a it was
i mean i don't be honest with you like
when i look at
old
interviews and old videos of myself i
cringe
like
that's the that was the on drugs kevin
wow
that was the that was the fat
you know unhealthy on drugs
like
i don't know it's beautiful because i
could look at my growth and see it but i
never want to be that person again right
ever in life
what um do you think was the turning
point for you to get sober and because i
just feel like you're more spiritually
just
intact like i feel like you're tapped in
yeah man i feel like the energy is
different i'll tell you something i
never told people before in the
interview i've been spiritual my whole
life
and
i think instead of owning up to my
responsibility
i would use drugs to kind of
dim my light so to say or turn my gift
down
a little
because when it's intense it's intense
when you're in tune you're in tune
and
it also i had a fear of
people looking at me weird for my
beliefs my belief system
but
everybody has to win their own way and
right now
i'm winning my own way
like for the first time in my life
i'm proud of myself like i could cry
right now i'm proud of myself i think
about everything i've been through
and i look at where i'm at now
and i always hear people say without a
test you can never have a testimony but
like for anybody that's suffering with
depression or you didn't been through
something in your past that was
traumatic we are not our past
every day you have an opportunity every
day is a new opportunity to find your
gratitude and be better than what you
was
the day before
a lot of people say that they figure
life out when they start moving with
gratitude
yeah you know what i'm saying just being
thankful for
just a little as [ __ ] man because
sometimes i feel like we get so wrapped
up in chasing
what's next we don't live in the moment
we don't appreciate what's going on
right now i was it
i was at this other spot downtown
i was there at
11 o'clock 11 30.
i left at 10 i was like i'm always be
there early
and then i went to the old building the
one across from the whole foods
i was dead 12 45
and then
it just was meant to be and then we came
over here mm-hmm but i used to record
him
well on the other side oh yeah next door
there's uh a studio two doors yeah i
used to recall here i recorded murder
for hire oh wow yes sir
yeah i got this place in uh february
before the pandemic starts this was
years ago yeah yeah but this i know this
place was i mean you know people use
this as a studio still i mean that's
kind of at night it's a recording studio
during the day we do the show here
um beautiful but yeah man uh
it's just been dope to see your growth
and i like i said i got to uh get an
early listen well the album is out now
so when this comes out it's out but i
listen to the whole album front to back
and it feels like
i guess it feels like what you just said
you're proud of yourself it feels like
this was a lot of it felt like a
therapeutic body of work
yeah i did a lot of releasing on this
project
i ruffled a lot of feathers
please find it in your heart to forgive
me i'm so not sorry yeah
even this uh super gremlin freestyle
you're going off five minutes straight
super gentle
yeah it was super general for you i mean
five minutes straight
just
delving through everything it was a
release
yeah man it was it just yeah that
freestyle is crazy like uh you know
obviously there's the the parts that
went viral but the parts that didn't go
viral where you're really kind of just
baring your soul on that thing
people
people gravitate
toward what they want to gravitate
toward
you know i guess it was like gumbo it
had a little something in their head
something for everybody for sure a
little ear candy for everybody i guess
yeah 100 um
how do you feel like um
because you know
i feel like it's 2022 you know maybe
the last five or six years in hip-hop
has been a real drug-infused vibe you've
been through your struggles with drug
addiction
what is some advice you would give up
and coming artists who maybe where you
were are at where you were maybe a
couple of years ago right now that maybe
you want to change their lives
it's not a bad thing
at all
like
these are people that choose to
self-medicate and i don't judge
but
i pray that everybody finds their way
eventually because
when i was on that level
i was doing what people on that level
did
i guess so to say yeah you know it's
about frequency it's about raising your
vibration
and
i used to use drugs it's more like a
coping mechanism yeah i guess so to say
alcohol too as a vice
i got on alcohol i never drank
i never drank but i got on alcohol like
2
000. 18
19
it was like maybe 18 or 19. that's not
long ago yeah and i just
i just i just wanted to feel good i just
wanted to numb everything and not feel
it
and that's what but i'm making it like i
was just a big alcoholic right right
right right because i really can't drink
i can't you have a little tolerance yeah
i got a low toners like you give me one
or two shots i'm
you're you're you're on a level he's
over with i'm sauced up yeah so
but i saw a live that i was on live one
time and i was on it i was like man
that's embarrassing look at yourself and
i started talking to myself i'm like
man come on that's not him what were
like the dr like your drugs of choice
like if you were coping like what would
be was it was it lean was it bills i
used to drink a lot of lean
i don't think i ever sat down with you
to do an interview and i wasn't just
fresh off the cup mm-hmm
it's a hard thing to kick right drink a
lot of lean
and
i didn't probably smoke more weed than a
chimney
are you off weed period
yeah i went through my phase well i'm
off of it
but
once i finish this this run
i want to go somewhere and just smoke
relax just relax and just smoke
i just want to smoke i just really want
to just get high and just relax
and that's nothing like that man i think
about nothing man there's nothing like
getting high and just
looking in the sky right i want to but
i'm just too focused right now i respect
the two so bad but i'm just too focused
have you done any psychedelics like what
kind of psychedelics mushrooms uh
ayahuasca you know cause i
i know right now shroom psilocybin is
something i i don't i hate to say these
aren't um
i'm in a medicine tribe i come from a
medicine tribe
my mother's side of the family they
native to this land um
so you've done
psilocybin yeah
well i don't know what the shrooms
mushrooms i grow my own mushrooms that's
amazing golden teachers golden teacher
is a good shroom strain and to be honest
with you
it's the spiritual aspect of the
mushroom you know what's crazy is i've
i've been paying attention to you the
last like few years and i'm like
i have a feeling gates is like woke in
that space i just got that feeling i've
been yeah i just never talked about it
i've been it's such a powerful thing to
like when i see people i hate to say
this when i see people take
mushrooms and they like i take it with
candy that's processed sugar
you're not respecting the spirit of the
mushrooms the mushroom spirits like what
the beautiful thing about mushrooms
they heal what needs to be healed if a
tree is dying
under the under i'm not trying to be our
what they call it all nerdy right no no
no this is but apache mama mother earth
the earth is our mother
she was here long before us she'll be
here long after we leave
okay
under the ground
the roots are connected like this all of
the trees are connected if one tree over
here is the can
then what the mushrooms do is
they'll grow in a line you obviously the
mushrooms they always grow in the line
from one tree to the other
they tap down into the root system
and they bring energy from one tree to
the other
that's hot
advanced that nature is nature is more
advanced than we will ever be that they
communicate
like i know they sound weird but the
trees
they communicate with one another that's
like
if you know anything about harvesting
flowers
santa maria
like that's i hear people say weed on
like i like to address it by her her
name like it's a spirit
like marijuana is a spirit santa maria
something that is spirit
when you harvesting
you can't harvest
your flowers in the same room with the
other flowers they give off enzymes and
other flowers how do they communicate
like that
it's far more advanced than we even know
we will ever understand so
every
everything has an essence and when i say
native to this land i'm talking about
the taino indians
you know it like the taino indians is
made up of everything they made up a
choctaw cherokee everything a pet
everything because they was taken from
this land and dispersed all over the
caribbean during slavery so that's why
you got taino indians in jamaica
all the way around the caribbean to
puerto rico
so that's why like i said a taino like
they
native yeah i feel like the way plants
communicate the way ants communicate i'm
just saying that because if somebody
listens they're gonna be like you said
native american you know or you were a
very said his mother was poor you know
and so i just yeah i was giving a little
bit in case cause they love people love
to critique me for some reason
yeah i've gotten super high and just
thought how the [ __ ] do trees talk to
each other
how do ants talk to each other like
there's like a a frequency it's like an
electromagnetic pulsation
[Music]
it's electric that's why your phone
don't work around trees
that's wild that's real
uh have you ever had like a really
therapeutic uh because you know
sometimes uh for people who don't know
if you do shrooms they got a
cert they've got
certain levels of doses right there's
there's micro dosing and then there's
the hero's dose which is what people do
when they just want to like work through
30 years of [ __ ] in one sitting have you
ever had like a therapeutic moment on
shrooms i'm a big shroom guy so yes sir
yeah
was it something because i know i know a
few people who've like literally had
life-changing experiences yes sir you've
had that experience yes sir do you
remember like what it was or
because some i don't think people
understand i think people don't do it
think it's like you take shrooms and you
hallucinate or you see see things that
aren't there which it's more of like
this
it pulls back what's already there right
here's your neuropaths
it may have
the beautiful thing about the body is if
we've experienced trauma
our bodies will suppress that trauma
so we won't have to keep reliving it it
won't have to hurt us what happens is
you may you may be exhibiting a behavior
that stems from a traumatic past
so once you sit
and really respect the mushrooms and sit
with them
and ask yourself why am i like this why
did why do i do this why do i do that
and it'll be revealed to you everything
all of the answers are within nothing
external could ever add value
have you ever done the thing
i was gonna say have you ever
have you ever smoked the toad as mike
tyson would call it
the dmt
come on bufo i don't know what bufo is
that's the toe yeah well it's two
different way it's two different
toes
toe medicine one is bufo
that's where you smoke the when they rub
his back right that's what i'm talking
about where you free base it and then
the other one
where you clean your lymphatic system is
combusito
tumble and they take well it's the
steal the same poison but they put it on
you they burn you
and put it on your skin that sounds
great i haven't heard of that have you
done uh have you have you tried that
like i said i i'm in a medicine trap
that's fire man i'm so scared to try it
because i hear you're kind of gone for
like you know 15
yeah
like you hit it and then you're just you
just kind of i'm not saying that i ever
tried it but i'ma say you're gonna be
gone for like 10 minutes
but it's gonna feel like you've been
gone
for years
heard that i feel like you've been gone
for a long time but you only been gone
for 10 minutes
but
that's just those are just
starter kids like ayahuasca and excuse
excuse me mother ayahuasca
because you got to be respectful when
you're speaking to these spirits that
are strong as medicines that come from
the earth
but
they just start up starting kids to me
they just let you know what's already in
you
you can reach these same levels through
controlled breathing meditation
you can reach these levels
you can unlock the dmt that's naturally
produced in your body through breathing
i didn't know that yeah so all of these
feelings that we're trying to feel we
can unlock they're there
yeah there's just certain uh things that
kind of help i guess jump start you know
yeah it's like a jump start like a
starter kit it helps you understand and
realize what's already there
yeah ayahuasca is something i i know you
gotta have like a shaman and
you know
probably prepare
with your diet before you do something
like that yeah it's a diet like well
that's a special diet yeah
all liquids
no food you don't want any dense energy
you want to
vibrate at the highest frequency
possible
and when you hold space you hold in a
sacred space the ceremony
um a lot of people don't talk about it i
mean i don't care to really talk about
it because
when you hear about it you hear all
these yeah man it was a trip it's not a
trip like
it's not a drug
it's not something you do recreationally
right
yeah
i think that's the difference i think
like even with shrooms which is
obviously a lot more mild than ayahuasca
but
it's like you're in like when you take
it what's your intent because that's
probably what you're gonna get out of it
you gotta it's better when you do
anything
you should state your intentions
you should do be intentional with
everything you do you're drinking water
i mean water is living
i'm not trying to sound weird but it's a
spirit
it's living
life
water is life without
you know eccentric people right now
there's nothing wrong with being an
eccentric guy man
i'm not trying to sound like that
what did you you kind of pulled this out
of me yeah man if it was if it was
talking about some music or some [ __ ]
then yeah but
it's like we kind of you kind of pulled
this out of me and it's just like coming
out because i usually don't have these
conversations especially in interviews
right right you um obviously you're in
great shape right now you're right yeah
i'm fearful square yeah man um
what dietary things are you doing that
kind of have gotten obviously you're
hitting the gym but in terms of just
like that out of all three times a day
in the gym i got skinny got all that
alcohol which kind of helped me block
out of myself yeah
i was just saying we could get to the
adderall which by the way if you ever
edit video all the video editors i know
are on adorama god bless him no i um i
tried this is my first time speaking
about it i i tried out a wrong
i ain't gonna say i tried it i did it
as a pre-workout
i did adderall and pre-workout at the
same time yeah i was in the gym like
i was on a mission in my mind
it don't stay focused
well then it didn't stay focused
and then thank god uh for ambrosia
they came out with this mushroom
pre-workout yeah a lot of people are
doing it yeah
yeah i know people who will micro dose
before their workout no i'm i'm i'm on
um ambrosia okay pre-workout i'm okay
right now that's interesting big handful
of mushrooms i'll take some and recharge
so the adderall though kind of got you
like super focused to get in the gym
initially when you tried it
yeah
yeah i guess
that's what you want to say yeah i it's
a very uh
they say it's like what's that that
limitless pill and that move that movie
where you take it and you you could get
[ __ ] done it's not like that but
i lost a lot of weight
like when people tell me when people
used to say you had surgery i used to
look at it offensively but like you know
i looked that good that you think i had
surgery but no
they thought you had like a male bbl or
something i think that's wild i think
that's what i don't i about to say i
don't know because i never had that
surgery of course i had been shot before
and i had surgery on my leg
and that was just horrific
and i was like i never willingly undergo
that type of screw yeah you'll never go
under the knife unless you have to yeah
i'm not doing it forgive me i get mine
out the mud which my fitness journey
took a little longer but the beautiful
thing about it was
when i first started working out i was
still doing drugs
then i noticed that
i started slacking up on the drugs
because it was like
you know i don't have any energy to get
up and work out in the morning then i
noticed my work i started being able to
work out more proficient mm-hmm
if that's the right word yeah i mean
efficient proficient whatever
efficiently we get it efficiently yeah
so
i noticed that and then i also noticed
that
once i started making small diet changes
it's like i wanted to take my singing
sears when i was on tour
and i was reading about a little things
that caused mucus build up and
i was reading about animal products
so i'm vegan vegan vegan vegan when i'm
on tour
when i'm not on tour i'm vegan
but i still eat animal products like
cheese or eggs i love cheese that's well
i love cheese
um i love steak vegan cheese is terrible
i don't want to say that because they
got some vegan cheese that's good i
haven't had i haven't had any of it yeah
they got some vegan cheese that's kind
of good but you're right yo what up man
we got to stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good folks at blue
chew that's right go to bluetooth.com
fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
bouchu
it is the wave uh how about this the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis getting delivered right to your
door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[ __ ] like you were [ __ ] never
[ __ ] before your dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and socked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com
and use that promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechew.com let's get back to the
interview
the mucus of dairy causes so much mucus
it's like crazy like and i couldn't and
it affects my singing
and
then i started reading about
like
animal products
and
when you're not getting enough
chlorophyll in your body because
chlorophyll is what helps metabolize
animal products
but when you're not getting enough
chlorophyll you feel like damn that's
why they always feed you vegetables
with the steak yeah it helps you digest
it
so and you can have steak once every two
weeks
all things within moderation so i had to
get off of the i'm extra vegan to have
imbalance
yeah i think that there is also like
health benefits to having animal protein
that you probably won't be able to i
like the way i feel when i'm vegan i do
steak every two weeks is a nice but
compromise that's my reward like when i
work super hard i have a cheat day every
sunday
um
sunday's a good cheat day yeah that's
the best cheat day
yeah
that's uh when i'm on like when i'm like
trying to be on my [ __ ] and i'm trying
to eat good i always save sundays i love
cheeseburgers oh man but
i'm gonna have to really curtail it
because i'm about to be going on tour
soon
got a twitter new album
you uh i love cheeseburgers can you give
me if you could rank the top five fast
food cheeseburgers from one to five
we're talking major chains not talking
like the spot on the corner that you
love if we had to go from one to five
best fast food burgers because i always
fight with people about how good
mcdonald's is because i think it's fire
i'ma be honest it's not the burger it's
the mustard the onions the ketchup and
the pickles at mcdonald's that make day
cheese and then you put the fries on the
burger you do that too
i get that number nine with the two
cheeseburgers do you ever dip it dip
your burger barbecue sauce
of course
with the fries oh god please no i love
mcdonald's i'd be like yo if mcdonald's
was trash it wouldn't be the number one
restaurant in the world now it might be
trash for you
but
oh all things and all things in
moderation yeah and everybody got
something on that mcdonald's menu they
[ __ ] with yeah i love the pancakes oh
the [ __ ] hot cakes i get the hot
cakes yes and i put the i put the butter
on there and then i put strawberry jelly
on there then i drizzle the serve that's
why i like that mcgriddle because but
i'm weird though they got this
restaurant called raisin canes
the best [ __ ] sauce i go get it i go
get the pancakes
and i go get wendy's french fries and i
go get raisin cane's chicken fingers and
i eat i rap
i'm weird i wrap my i wrap my chicken
finger inside the pancake
do you introduce the cane sauce into
this equation i got to and the honey
mustard yeah
so let me get this straight you'll go to
mcdonald's
get me i mean listen me and you both
we're on the same wavelength of fat
[ __ ] here we are food tastes better
when you wait to your cheat day that's
real because it's almost like like on
mondays i'd be like
six more days
so let me get this straight though i
don't want to just pass this over you'll
go to mcdonald's you'll get the hotcakes
you go to wendy's you'll get there first
get like 10 orders a hot cake you'll get
wendy's fries wendy's fries with the
wendy's barbecue sauce which is the best
barbecue sauce yeah it is
and then you get raisin cane's chicken
raisin cheese and we just combine all
three on a cheat day into some just
metamorphically amazing
i take all of my pancakes
people just sit there and watch me i put
the
i put the butter on them i put the
strawberry jelly i put a little bit of
syrup
i take my
my um wendy's fries
it's so weird my process i put all my
wendy's fries down i put my chicken
fingers across them
i take the lemons and i squeeze my
lemons across it i drizzle the hot sauce
across it then i take the barbecue sauce
and dribble my barbecue sauce across it
then i put my fries
and my chicken finger on my um i make
like a little burrito on on a hat cake
and i just eat it and people be like
what do you do with the cane sauce
though i dip it okay okay okay i just
dip it
like every other bite i might dip it
from
from the raisin cane sauce to the honey
mustard or vice versa no man
i'm not gonna lie i'm intrigued you
talking to the same person that put
strawberry jelly and grape jelly on
their cheeseburgers
i've actually uh i'm just weird i went
to some like fancy place recently and
they had um
i bought a cheeseburger and i had bacon
jam
yeah they've been doing the bacon jam i
don't care for that i don't eat pork
yeah but it was it wasn't bad i i
understand
like your logic there i just can't cause
i know
i know the truth behind it so i can't
you can't eat the swine i just can't eat
it they don't have any veins
that is kind of crazy they don't detox
and they'll eat anything
but they really like some of the
smartest animals on earth
they're super smart they're survivors
they're super smart but i just
cause they got them sometimes they used
to run across my land
on my farm you'll see them in the
morning and they got a way they
communicate with each other and
everything they like little people
well you're muslim muslims can't eat pig
is that right yeah i don't eat pork yeah
you've also um on your
i want to shout out to uh fredo bang who
you gave some love to in this super
general freestyle yeah it's one of the
uh i don't know who the other guy was
because you should be in team nba being
a team okay so uh as
two of the guys who
now he's watching oh
give you love i was watching a thing
like a documentary
and he was on a rap in the streets of br
and he was like kevin gates and he
saluted me and i was like man
it feel good because a lot of people
don't do that well i do feel like your
influence on a generation
is very
understated
i do feel like you know the
2014-2015 wave that you had going i was
living in florida at the time i was
living in tampa so i was very much
you know you were very
big in that market
um
and i feel like somehow
you don't get enough credit for
a lot of what's going on right now
specifically even just with your city
you know what i'm saying
i'm not even looking for the it just
feel good when people do salute right
they just feel good
that's why i love my concerts i'm
nervous before every concert because i
want to give it the best performance
ever
i work out before every concert
i get there get the nerves out i get
there a day or two early and work out
i stay in tip-top shape so i can be
performers ready at all times
i've seen you
do a show
after the show do an after party
this was in tampa then go to the studio
no no no you went to club sky in tampa
after wild splash
and
you walked through the entire crowd
and hugged every person in this in the
crowd you're by myself by yourself
no security you literally
i mean we're talking about a club of
full 1500 people and this is like
this is i think you might have had two
phones out at this time
um
and i never seen anybody i was grateful
embrace
the people that were there to support
them the way you did that day i was like
this is i've never seen them the people
that love me for real so i was i was
grateful
i was grateful for that moment
i was grateful
so
i had to
i had to touch the people because i was
grateful yeah
has that ever gone wrong
no
well
i had a situation where
and it's so crazy
it was
it was the work i want to say it was the
worst thing that had ever happened to me
in my life but it really was the best
thing because
i wouldn't be where i'm at right now
i got a level of freedom that
most people only wish they had
but i was kind of blackballed
what happened in polk county somehow
yeah i was kind of black bald like i
never made contact
with the girl i tried to i didn't even
know that it was a girl
i just seen hands instead of grabbing
because the light was so bright right
but at the same time me being who i am
i'm gonna defend myself right that's
like
somebody to talk about
man bro how you would feel if if that
that could have been my little sister my
auto did that to your mama i don't have
no pigs also that's your sec you still
yeah like i'm supposed to be your safe
space i can't see who it is yeah i did
that to your mama right how to do that
to your grandfather i don't have no
picks
win loser maybe that's all it was gonna
be
like i don't have no pics like
this is what i i tell people that
and
it's like nobody understand they still
throw that at me say every time every
nine days but i'm like
my footage wasn't even permissible in
court i never made contact
it was no damages for her
i played soccer my whole life your head
would have came off your body
my daughter was on stage with me i had
to move my daughter to the back of the
stage
right yeah i think like and at that time
at that time being young
being ignorant being out the streets
you know
it's like
i'm a natural protector so i ain't
thinking about who down now i'm
protecting my tribe i'm a chief and i
feel like the stage if you're the guy
who also goes in the crowd and embraces
your fans you should also
have the stage be your safe place this
is where i'm but it just it's just
crazy that it happened i was living
there when it happened it was just crazy
when it happened because i never made
contact but the world just blew it up
like he just did and i'm like what
then i end up going to jail
the charge
is a 400 fan i went to jail for six
months
so crazy for six months
like i was supposed to have a tea party
with my daughter
and it's like a live tour
like
i miss like two of her birthdays
it was just crazy i did six months
and then
i was already fighting the charge in
chicago which i was innocent on that
charge also
and i ended up doing 33 months
which i was supposed to do 36 months but
the judge showed lien you see he didn't
abuse discretion so i guess that was a
good thing
but
i was innocent
but
i could also say that was the best thing
that ever could have happened to me
because
i wouldn't be where i met right now if
that wouldn't happen
like that was the best thing that could
have happened what were the cause
some people
go through that and they come out on the
other side of it worse for it and some
people go through and they come out on
the other side of it with more growth
and to come out better
how did what were the things that you
kind of took away from that
is
obviously sitting down for 33 months is
a serious chunk it's
it's trying at times you know
but my eyes was open
to reality and reality is harsh in the
world is a very cruel place
it is
and every time i meet people that's
dealing with depression and suffering i
tell them man the world's a cruel place
trust me i know
but i had time to sit with myself
like the six months in florida i was
like man yeah i'm gonna do it this way
when i go back out there
but
i wasn't all the way ready
then when i went to chicago
i was like
i'm gonna do it this way after like
maybe a year
but as i got longer into the bed
i just was like
it had stripped me it broke me all the
way down
to
being more appreciative being more
appreciative
and that's
that's when i that's when i really sit
with myself for the first time
in the other time i went to jail you
know i was in the mix
right this time it was like
i had matured
you know this is my first time ever
taking yoga because this is my first
time being in a minimum security prison
any other time i go to maximum security
prisons well we just in this [ __ ]
thugging
you know but it's structured
you know our prison is structured
and
that's the first time i had ever like
experimented with yoga
and i liked it
at first though i was like i ain't about
to do no yoga that's some old [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah for sure yeah yeah [ __ ] you go
do the yo right my cellar kept on
telling me man i'm telling you man you
just gotta do it his name t-bone man
shout out to t-bone
yeah
so yoga i mean yeah that is interesting
that would have used the tim come on
papa we got to go do yoga come on
he's man they got yoga
and i'm like i'm about to go do no yoga
man i'm telling you he couldn't even he
was having knee problems he started
doing yoga not as he don't even he's not
even in pain anymore come on you got to
go
so i'm like ah yeah but just
one day i went i gave it a try for the
first time i said man this [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
man the first maybe the first two poses
i got into
i immediately had to go to the bathroom
and [ __ ] wow and it just yoga started
curving my appetite and things of that
nature but when i came home upon being
re-inserted back into society i kind of
like got away from those things
but then when i got back into fitness
i was like you back on the yoga yeah i
do yoga every day what are the benefits
for somebody for someone who
says the same thing you said this is
some bitch-ass [ __ ] hey i know it's
gonna sound crazy
but when i meet people that do yoga i'd
be like you're a gangster
cause i know
it's been a journey for me
and the beautiful thing is yoga is
non-judging
it's just you being one with yourself
it's non-judging it's just you focus on
yourself you focus on your breathing
and every breath you try to deepen the
stretch
and it's very very it's therapeutic
it's like you get a hive from it wow and
you release like one time i was doing a
pigeon pose
that's where you had your leg like a
little ear and your other leg that's
when you open your hip
and
i was opening my hip flexor
and
when i was in the stretch i just started
crying
she started crying tears
and i later she just put her hands on my
back
and she say the energy that you're
feeling is not your own
you're having a release
you're having an emotional detox she
said this is
psychic debris that you picking up on
just release the things that no longer
serve you
she said no
say it say i release all of the things
that no longer serve me i said it
and then my new yoga coach
i was telling her that my left
hip not as flexible as my right heel
and she was like well
you know your left side of your body is
feminine your right side is masculine so
you should ask your hip what is it that
you're trying to teach me
so like i talked to my body parts now
because
once i start saying what is it that
you're trying to teach me or what is it
that you need me to release
things started changing in my life
like it's crazy like when we get rid of
baggage
like our bodies
are lighter
it's just
the things around us weigh us down
they're anchors
that could be people too right it could
be of course there's really
one of the biggest things
so
when i every time i do my stretch nah my
pitching pose on the left side i always
tell my hip thank you
like thank you for trusting me thank you
for releasing thank you for teaching me
thank you for serving me
i thank my feet thank you for all the
stability you give me because i'm out
you're stepping on these over i'm just
i mean you do have a song do you have a
song on the album called stepping
and by the way yeah um
great body of work
i i know that you would kind of uh
acknowledge that the last project maybe
wasn't up to par it was it was beautiful
as far as the uh the just the i guess
how it performed
it wasn't about the numbers it was
beautiful the project was beautiful it
was a beautiful project
i believe the project may have been
ahead of its time
like big gangster when it came out it
was ahead of his time right now it's
just
out of here
so
the project was a beautiful project but
it was everything that i was going
through emotionally during that time
that was one of my roughest times just
personally away from the music you were
just going during during the making of
i'm him that was one of the roughest
times like after the
during like toward the end of the luca
brassie 3 going into the i'm him that
was one of the roughest times of my life
but i was trying to mask it
and pretend
but people that know me they knew
but i was dying on the inside i was
suffering
and that album kind of came out before
his time but it's beautiful that it came
out
because
i could sit back nine appreciate it and
be reflective like look what i overcame
it's got to be a hard thing to be going
through some personal [ __ ] like that oh
man and you can't say nothing while
being kevin gates and you gotta and you
gotta be perfect all the time
yeah you gotta be perfect
that's crazy like you got you
experienced every human emotion that it
is even more so cause you wear your
heart on the sleeve you're a lover
you're a giver
but
no matter what you do the world beats
you up
you get beat up when you go home it's
like nothing you ever do is good enough
so you never really feel welcome
anywhere you go
that's crazy you know what i'm saying
like this come from being a child like
get out
it's like you never really feel welcome
anywhere you go because it's like
if i'm not
being what
everybody want me to be
then are you gonna still love me the
same
and that's just what i was dealing with
like man i work so hard so other people
can enjoy
it's my first time enjoying myself
enjoying my life when you're someone
like you
who's
a lot of people depend on it's like it's
almost like you're so much to so many
people
but like
and you know i'm in that same position i
was taught wrong
okay i was taught wrong
we wasn't taught right we was taught
wrong
and as a child
when you
a provider look out for people you
develop this sensor
i'm only as good as what i could do for
everybody around me mm-hmm if you can't
be used you useless that's real [ __ ] but
when you love somebody as you love
yourself
the way you love somebody else is a
reflection of how you love yourself
you know like if you hungry and i cut up
some fruit and bring you some fruit
you know this is what i would eat right
i look at my body like my temple now
right this is you know what i'm saying
so the way that you love others is the
way that you love yourself because money
isn't always the solution for everything
it's really an enabler it's a band-aid
it doesn't fix anything
anything that needs to be fixed has to
be done on the inside
did you ever get to the point where
everybody comes to you right you have
kids
uh
obviously you're in a public
relationship you have the labels you got
all you know people in your entourage
your manager whatever
but it's like who do i go to when i'm
going through some [ __ ] because you're
the you're kind of the leader i know who
i go to who do you go to the microphone
that's your therapy that's right yeah i
got songs that i never released probably
won't ever release but i had to get it
out that's how i mean
that's real you have that outlet which
is great i mean
you know and then working out going to
the gym
and i think that's why people love you
so much because people have such an
emotional connection to you because
you've been so
vulnerable on
on records over the years yeah it takes
greater courage to show exhibit
vulnerability than it does to be a tough
guy
that's real when i at the times that i
was being tough it was out of fear
a fear of being vulnerable
the reason i learned how to fight and
took all these different martial laws
and all of this because i had a fear of
being weak or feared being vulnerable
fear being taken advantage of
the hardest thing for me to ever learn
how to do was surrender
that's crazy um
what up y'all hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the bootleg
head podcast our family at odd socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen
odd socks now has the underwear that's
right tapatio draws on that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
you uh acknowledged
dolph being right there with you dolph
ain't gone he's with you he's right here
in the booth with me you with me right
now
dolph was a good friend of mine um a
great guy somebody who was a leader
somebody who uh
you know obviously what happened to him
was a tragedy but um
everything happened for a reason
nothing happens without the permission
of the creator
and i know for a fact that he was in
tune with the creator
he come to me sometime my brother mia's
economy sometimes i don't know why i'm
saying this but
dude i've had a few artists mozzie one
of them who's who brought you up as not
that much
someone from sacramento no i mean i i
i've had artists who brought you up like
in terms of like
you're kind of like their spiritual
advisor loki like artists even money
baguio who i know you said you guys
aren't as close but i remember
interviewing
a few years ago that's my bro but i i
know that he like he had mentioned that
like you had kind of helped get him into
you know
exploring his face you know what i mean
yeah because
i look at it like this
what i eat not gonna make another person
[ __ ] and what you eating are gonna make
me [ __ ]
but the beautiful thing about it is
we may not be brothers and sisters in
faith but we still brothers and sisters
in humanity
anything that you go through i'ma feel
it
i mean we get lost on the exterior but
we all the same on the inside
to an extent right right
to an extent yeah
that's that's fair
how much flack have you gotten for this
beyonce bar
nobody say nothing to me i do like how
you preface the bar with uh if you guys
are swingers uh
and in general uh that that
ruby rose replied to your to your uh
to your to be honest
and this with all due respect
that's one of the most beautiful women
in the world
like
i sit in the trap with all the monsters
they say the same thing like
all i did is say what everybody think
that's fair you're the most beautiful
woman in the world like i would drink
your piss like
what the [ __ ] like come on man like what
the [ __ ] beyonce's piss obviously yeah
right here in my mouth what's that but
i'm just saying like
you gotta think i i speak for the [ __ ]
that's incarcerated that sit there and
watch these people on tv and everything
this is what everybody's thinking
this is true i mean beyonce is we always
have talks like
that's like that's like say if this was
right here this you know this is my
water bottle it's my wife
i feel good knowing that
everybody in the world want
this what i have what's mine
yeah i'm winning yeah
i'm living y'all dreams every night so
you know
people the other people that took a
disrespect y'all just scared to say but
y'all scared to be
who y'all are
i guess
by the way i don't put that much thought
into stuff i just speak from the heart
at what point in time did you realize
in life that squirt was pissed
it's not
it kind of is i just say that but it's
not it's like it's like a
portion of it is because you're i got a
question okay for you yeah every woman
that you've been intimate with sexually
were they squirtles
i think every woman is a squirter every
woman is a squirter but did you make
every woman that you've been with
sexually squirt every woman that i cared
everyone i cared about yes
because
to make a woman squirt is an art
i agree it's an art
like i i feel like any woman i ever was
with that i cared about pleasing yes
it's a release right so it's a art
if
if i don't make this woman come if i
don't make this woman squirt
i didn't do my job as a professional
dicksman
like i didn't get a i didn't get a a on
my dig report your dick report card yeah
yeah so
i want to always you know
this is a brand name
i want to always have a good dick report
you know and i and i mean that with all
due respect
to whoever listening you know what i'm
saying listen buddy we i'm there over
here over here
over here
i look at a woman like art like
i ain't a please my partner i'm a
pleasure activist
i get off on seeing
whoever i'm intimately involved with get
off my partner
yes as someone who's crazy this whole
interview just went left but well shout
out you know you know what's interesting
because i always tell that to you you
started all spiritual yeah we're talking
about squirt
hey man
but i just noticed like
when you do things selfishly
like the womb
is his own entity it's very spiritual
right the womb knows
if you being selfish
and she won't release
i'm like you i've had my wife
literally squirted my mouth multiple
times you know what i'm saying let's do
that buddy you know what i'm saying
what are we doing if we ain't trying to
please the ones we love
what yes sir ain't nothing like having
your girl ride your face and then things
go you know but the thing is though the
reason i brought up the piss thing is
you might have a crazy night
and the sheets are [ __ ]
mattress gets wet you wake up the next
morning
it's a lot a little pissy of a smell you
gotta have a [ __ ] room
the [ __ ] room yeah
you got a [ __ ] room
and you got a [ __ ] room in the sleep
room yeah
that's interesting so you you were just
destined to play room in a lay room i
don't even like the word
i don't like the word sex i just say it
so everybody know what i'm talking about
right but it's spiritual it's spiritual
unification i pray before i have sex
this is spiritual
you'll pray before sex yes every time
every time it's spiritual that's
interesting
yeah i mean i i i
you'll pray during sex yeah i'll just be
thanking god
would you ever stop and be like give me
a sec no no no no but just in your head
no i say it out loud
like if like if i'm just in it
and i'm just really punching that dick
i'm talking about punching that dick in
her stomach i'll just be like yes lord
yes lord cause this
i never thought like coming from where i
come from
me
i know people look at me like kevin case
but i don't see kevin gates right i see
regular old kevin so i'm like
man it's a blessing to be hitting a big
booty [ __ ] you got a body of uh a
a work of art in front of you i'm
talking about i got a workout oh and i'm
time out
i'm out just having my way and it's
making homemade big buddy [ __ ] i'mma
hear from no bag it just it's just a
blessing to me because i ain't you know
we didn't grow up just having this in my
living room you know right you mentioned
uh you and bundle of brittany had a
little
stint on this uh on the freestyle on the
song yeah yeah yeah on the song i did
yeah you said uh in woodland hills you
were uh with bundle of britney and then
she ended up okay what's the question
she's a sweetheart she's a great girl
she's been on the show a couple of times
what i i mean i feel like uh with
someone like brittany she probably gets
a a worse rep than deserved
um all the good people get the worst
reps
all the good people
had a worse reputation look at me
that's true people say the worst [ __ ]
about me i think there's just a lot of
misconceptions about you no it's the
narrative there's people just say the
worst [ __ ] about me i don't care yeah
i'm used to it so anybody that i know
i don't judge
so i don't care like what the world said
about bootleg kid
i'm gonna know
how i [ __ ] with him based on how i
[ __ ] with him
do you think um
for you what is the misconception that
maybe
doesn't bother you to this day but when
it comes to your narrative that's out
there i don't know i don't even pay
attention anymore i don't care
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it used to i used to
get upset like man bro
i don't even care
yeah i think like uh not as many people
in in an industry where every time the
cameras are on people have to get there
are you good
i feel like every time i see you i swear
to god
every time i've ever seen you
just period you're just
it's
you're just unapologetically yourself at
all times no i ain't doing no
apologizing you got to forgive me
because i'm not sorry right
i'm not sorry
well i'll be sorry for telling the truth
or doing what's true to me
that's real why i ain't bothering nobody
so high
like what's the big deal i don't bother
nobody
people just find reasons to be upset
with me
for no reason right
that is real man
yo i got to show you i don't bother
nobody i'm talking about i just had the
beer my dog
i got this this bullet how old micro
exotic bullet his name dick i had him
forever like he was my
emotional support animal but i guess
he left because he felt like you know
you don't need me anymore he passed away
yeah damn you know that was like my best
friend i used to tell him everything he
never told us all
you know i i'm a big dog guy i got two
dogs so i've had to bury i had to bury
my english bulldog three years ago she
had a brain tumor
and uh
yeah i had to put her to sleep so i can
only imagine man your dog's name was
dick though that's a great name for a
dog
i have a dog named larry well
his name was really richard
dick for short yeah but he was rich he
just looked rich
that's just what his name is i'm a fan
of giving dogs normal names my dog's
name is larry
and jeff
i have two dogs jeffrey lebowski and
larry david it's normal names
you know it's just it's just the things
that that i go through every day and
deal with like nobody ever asked me how
i'm feeling
i don't know i just suck it up and roll
i've been doing it my whole life
but back to the question like people
what have i done
i don't bother nobody i just if you
don't like it hey don't don't watch
don't consume
don't i hate i hate his music don't
listen to it cool
yeah
i didn't do it for you anyway i did it
for me have you been able to um
anytime i've lost a dog it's been hard
for me to buy a new dog or get a new dog
have you
moved on and gotten a new animal or no
i've been i've been working on myself
like i do yoga i work out
and i go to the mu
studio and make music therapy
this project no features right am i
tripping because i feel like i ran
through the project and i didn't hear
anything well i i reached out to a few
people i wanted some features but you
know zero features though right maybe
they were too busy
is this your first album with no
features no
cause that because that's something that
we don't see anymore everyone's getting
features it's been it's
i don't think any of my albums ever had
features
uh i had pnb rock
on a song
me and trey songz you know
my brother ty dollar sign we did a song
together a long long time ago
i was on the isla deluxe album it came
out it wasn't on the original album i
don't think don't quote me on that
don't quote me people
but yeah that story of my life i reached
out to some people for some features
though
just didn't didn't come together maybe
they were too busy
that's interesting um maybe they did
that you know i think it's so one of the
craziest things i've seen in a long time
is
well not too crazy because with tick
tock things
are
you know the world's different now
you had a record that came out in 2013
14 thinking with my dick yeah that
has just resurfaced you guys reworked it
to radio i saw you brought the guy out
um the dude with the cup and uh cause it
was it was a moment yeah super moment we
had to live that moment together
yeah like uh how much like when you when
you reached out to that guy was he like
a fan fan or was he just like a fan of
that record because that was a that was
a that's my brother
that was a great moment man that's my
brother
we talking to dm all the time that's
funny and it's like
that's my brother we shared that moment
on stage together that we made history
they could never take that away from me
you know
what was uh your initial reaction to
having something like that go crazy on
tick tock because you know the tick tock
world is so different than the one i
don't really be on tick tock like i
don't know any i mean besides children i
don't know a lot of people i mean
it's so crazy i record videos and just
send them to
my people and they just put them on tick
tock
they do it for you yeah
you were kind of one of the first
artists that embraced
having a full-time videographer and
embraced documenting
[ __ ] on your youtube channel
like because
i didn't have a
platform so to say i guess so i used to
have to be not have to but my way of
connecting with people was
i used to make the lit clips on
instagram yes
this was before stories this is when you
only got like 15. you got 15 seconds and
it's it's a square yeah those are the
good old days
yeah no those were uh i i made a i'm
going to show you those are the good old
days everything's
it's just different now it's different
it's on steroids it's all stairs there's
no like room it's crazy because we were
just talking um
i was just having some conversations
with a with a good friend of mine about
uh who who used to have a residency in
vegas not too long ago like 2017 2016
and some of the nights that we may or
may not have had
in vegas that we are like yo
that was like four or five years ago and
the [ __ ] that we were doing back then we
could never do
in today's world just because of the
[ __ ] social media aspect and how much
more magnified everything is
that's not true
you can you just can't go on
social media look at it
see i
i had got off social media for like a
year and a half
and i just focused on myself
because it was leading to depression i
hadn't said this in a lot of interviews
before i was making comparisons i was
comparing other people's highlight real
to my real life right and the comparison
is the killer of all joy
so i wasn't finding my gratitude
but once i got off
instagram
for like the first
i think like the first week i used to go
to my phone and look and check cause i
and i was like damn
i'm addicted
that's an addiction man i'm addicted to
going look and it's the same pictures
over and over again most people's first
thing they do when they wake up grab
their phone and open up ig yeah i can't
do that because it takes my energy from
it i got to get up and go straight and
work out i can't talk to nobody you
won't touch your phone until you're done
working out well i got one phone that
don't have no apps on it it got all my
music and stuff on there that's my gem
phone but that's my most important phone
my little smartphone my other phones i
got all that [ __ ] on up but when i go to
sleep i cut my phones on airplane mode
because i read
that the transmission from the phone
they mess up your melatonin cycles
and you don't get the rest that you're
supposed to get
so you're not gonna have the energy that
you're supposed to have the next day so
i put my phones on airplane mode
and then
sometimes i forget they on airplane mode
and then you'll be right around all day
you'll be like man damn i'm tripping
whatever i missed it
anything i missed it wasn't meant for me
because anything that's meant for me it
ain't gonna miss me
so anything lost could be found again
except for time wasted i didn't waste
time today
i didn't get on the phone and talk
because if i get on the phone and talk
before i go to the gym i ain't even
gonna work out
and we ain't talking about nothing cause
you ain't did nothing but the same [ __ ]
that you do every day
you ain't did nothing spectacular like
we ain't doing nothing spectacular i'm
not doing nothing spectacular i do the
same thing every day but this is what
makes me feel good
yeah i've heard that a lot of uh
billionaires millionaires ceos
that's they have that morning routine
where you don't touch your phone until
you do something
productive
whether it's have breakfast my best stop
coffee come when i'm working up
my best thoughts it's something about
getting up early in the morning how
early
i'm up early maybe three a.m
i'm about to go to bed then maybe like 7
00 p.m 8 p.m if i'm like today i'm gonna
be finished at like six
so i'll probably get in about eight
wow
that's early but i'm gonna take me a hot
bear
with the salt i got my little
my little woo [ __ ]
and i'm gonna let my whole body relax
then i'm gonna lay down and go to sleep
and get rich so i can get up and go to
the gym and egg bed have you ever done
the um deprivation tank
time with the salt
now where it's like a it's like a pod
that they put you in you're in water
with the water with the saltines you
float yeah you float yeah and you can't
heal or feel nothing but just your own
take an hour have you done that have you
done it yeah one time it was almost like
i was high but i wasn't high
like when you're in there long enough
it's you start kind of like uh
not one say hallucinating you go inward
it's it's wild it's the journey inward
and a lot of people can't sit along with
themselves yeah
a lot of people can't sit with themself
it's an intense thing to do i'd suggest
everyone should go do it but
what's beautiful is when i'm in my
solitude that's when
all of my greatest ideas come
yeah i'd be like you know what this is
what i'm about to call my mountains hey
i call him from the gym all the time hey
we about to drop this uh song
we just dropped the song we about to
drop another one
hmm
yeah listen the album is crazy the intro
i know you just dropped the video for
the intro i love the inch i love how you
kick the album off thank you um i try
yeah do you feel like uh
in today's
landscape of artists
there's
another guy who kind of reminds you or
gives you the energy of kevin gates
that's out there
everybody's great in their own right
i don't even look at it like that
anymore
but everybody's great in their own right
whose energy do you appreciate right now
a new artist i don't even listen to a
lot of rap
so you got to forgive me what do you
listen to
god
god
y'all listen to god he's diamond for
sure yeah i listen to god but
i listened at a lot of rock and roll
like soft rock
oldies
not oldies but like 90s
like rock yeah so like uh
when you say soft rock knight he's like
dave matthews band or like i know about
david matthews band but
i like is and then i'm not a fan of a
whole
uh um a whole group of people i'm just a
whole collection of music it's just like
certain songs like a playlist like say
if i'm jogging it's going to be
one of my playlists it started i took
her out
it was a friday night
like that yeah then it might go from
there to
shun them with a haven't you people ever
heard of closing the goddamn door no
it's much better to face these sorts of
things with this poison rationality
at the disco oh no it's panic at the
disco so it's just my my playlist is
weird
yo who i would have never have thought
that you're a panic at the disco blink
182 guy i like their wordplay
panic at this i like they they were
playing that was a great era of rock
that i like green day too green day's
great another turning point a fox took
in a row
so i congratulate directs you where to
go
tattoos and memories are lasting on
trial
for what is worth it was worth all the
while
something unpredictable but in the end
is right
i hope you had the time of your life it
just i don't know it's just it's like
when you running
you get lost cause it's like you just
get lost
yo that's i'm weird i love green no
you're not we're great let's agree
that's one of the biggest bands ever
they had uh you know green day had a
broadway play for like five years about
one of their albums
so that's uh that's that's that's dope
but it's just it's just like when i'm on
a treadmill running
it's like
that's that
we going the distance have you ever
experienced any of that music live as a
fan
oh one time
one time
who'd you see live
oh
i forgot
i was at this atlantic
party
[Music]
and
dude was up there playing the guitar and
everything it wasn't ed sheeran he was
it was another dude but he played the
guitar he played every instrument and
sang and i was like man it's fly
i don't even remember his name someone
uh
i got a homie uh you know tech nine from
kansas city
if you say his name
like to
the
what you call the people that that uh
the it people the cool people they won't
know who he is don't know who it is but
if you say his name in a room just
random
like just say of random people
everybody will know who technine is you
know who
showed me how to
do my merch
travis and tignan i mean strange music
they're the merch gods
and they got the they the truth
encounters like but like it
like the it people try to act like you
know i don't know
but if you say his name like in a random
room full of people just
they just know
yeah they're uh fully vertical like no
other company that's independent they
own all the buses they own all the they
own all the prints i can hear trevor's
not man yeah man you know you start
doing the merch kevin
you know what i'm saying you [ __ ] around
and beating paid for the whole tour just
off merch before you go on the road
exactly they got their own you ever been
to they compound i've been i've seen it
all they got their own city they got it
all they got their own car wash they got
their own yes they should they got every
city no it's crazy and then the merch
thing is like like you said like if you
go to a tech show
anything you can put a strange music
logo on is for sale they got yo-yos they
got it
yeah
water bottles but i was saying tech uh
he told me one thing he does he's like
i'll
go to a city that's low-key
to experience music as a fan so if a
band i like and i told him that's what i
always wanted to do yeah go somewhere
and watch a concert as a fan yeah he's
like out me and my girl will hit the
road if there's a band i want to see
i'll find the most obscure city that
they're performing in
and just go enjoy the show like because
it's kind of hard to enjoy [ __ ] as a fan
anymore like if you're on his level
you're on your level you know what i'm
saying
you put that coronal mass on throw that
mask and throw that push iced on
and you're good man
well listen the album drops what's out
now this is going to be out by the time
the album comes out um
great body of work
anything else you got coming um
i don't have anything come up with my
tour but kaiser if you don't have it go
get it
if you don't want it you don't have to
go get it i still love you who are you
taking out on tour
i don't know yet last tour was ddg right
yeah that's my bro good guy man great
guy yeah super sweet dude he box he does
he does fight yes he does you got spar
he beat [ __ ] up do you guys ever spar no
yeah
yeah no ddg is a good dude yeah so
tour's coming album's out
um man i appreciate the time bro real
[ __ ] i hope people learn some [ __ ] from
this interview
i hope so too you know
outside of
pee and squirt being the same thing or
not being the same i mean i'm just
that's what everybody think
that's who don't think that
yeah unless you just blind and you just
if you don't think that then you if you
don't think that then you just
a [ __ ] up person
like you just you you denying the truth
there it is
appreciate you man oh [ __ ] yes sir
kevin gates